[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir bienvenue
dans votre émission 7,8 débat un tabou
se lève à l'université française
aujourd'hui certains étudiants lycéens
et salariés de l'université ont défilé
partout en france contre la réforme du
processus d'entrée aux facultés parcours
cette nouvelle plateforme remplace l'apb
et permet aux bâches et le d'éviter le
très décrié tirage au sort ou de se
retrouver sans affectation à la rentrée
cependant l'accès aux filières sous
tension se fait sous la forme d'un
examen de dossier est le premier pas
vers une sélection à l'université en
quoi cette réforme peut-elle changer le
devenir des facultés pour débattre de
cette question j'accueille autour de moi
aurore bergé bonsoir vous êtes députée
de la 10e circonscription des yvelines
mais aussi membre de la commission
éducation et culture au parlement en
face de vous j'accueille madame
catherine bizarre bonsoir vous êtes vice
présidente du conseil académique de
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines et versailles et vous êtes
aussi chargé de la formation
absolument à côté de vous nous
accueillons également monsieur naim
chipie bonsoir bonsoir pour cette
présidente de l'unité locale de l'unef
dans les yvelines
et vous vous êtes contre justement cette
nouvelle réforme alors tout d'abord
avant de commencer ce débat nous faisons
un nouveau point notamment sur parcours
sud
c'est donc une nouvelle plateforme qui
permet aux futurs bacheliers de proposer
dix choix dit ce voeu de leur choix pour
l'éducation supérieure pour cela la
plateforme est disponible depuis mi
janvier entre le 22 janvier jusqu'au 13
mars les bacheliers peuvent émettre
justement jusqu'à dix choix
ensuite c'est à l'université notamment
de étudier les différentes propositions
qui a commencé à émettre aussi avis à
partir du 22 mai ce jeu ne trompent pas
à partir de là ensuite découle un mois
des changes avec les étudiants pour
décider notamment de leur avenir à la
rentrée puis va s'ouvrir notamment une
nouveauté une procédure complémentaire
d'admission durant tout l'été jusqu'en
septembre pour faire en sorte qu'aucun
étudiant ne reste sur le carreau à la
rentrée alors sur le papier ça a l'air
parfait mais qu'en est il réellement
s'il vous plaît mais une première chose
ça correspond à un réel besoin c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui la licence à
l'université n'est pas ne répond pas aux
besoins d'orientation des étudiants les
statistiques nationales le montre on a
un tiers des étudiants qui réussit un
tir qui échoue et un tir qui abandonne
ses statistiques là sont évidemment au
révélatrice d'un dysfonctionnement dans
le système donc la réforme va dans le
sens d'une meilleure orientation donc il
est il est évident qu'il fallait faire
quelque chose sur le territoire
toutefois l'université de versailles
peut se prévaloir de statistiques bien
meilleure que celle là donc c'est plutôt
positif
toutefois il fallait impérativement
mettre en place un dispositif qui permet
d'orienter puisqu'en fait j'entends
beaucoup le terme sélection attendue
mais il est surtout question
d'orientation
il s'agit d'affecter au mieux les
étudiants dans l'enseignement supérieur
en fonction de leurs attentes et en
fonction de leur projet de formation
mais par contre aujourd'hui la loi n'est
toujours pas votée il ya des sénateurs
dans l'opposition qui disent qu'ils
veulent carrément bloquer ce processus
et a donc vous pensez vraiment pouvoir
tenir ces délais absolument
là aujourd'hui ça passe dans les
conseils l'université s'est emparé
complètement du sujet d'ailleurs je
tiens à remercier nos équipes puisque en
réalité on travaille pour la réussite
des étudiants une ce sont les
universités qui sont à pied d'oeuvre
depuis depuis le début du mois de
décembre pour que parcours sup ouvre
effectivement au 15 janvier a mieux
rempli les attendus et les capacités
d'accueil les conditions d'examen des
candidatures l'unaca justificatifs donc
tout ça c'est cali d'accord cependant
aujourd'hui des étudiants contrairement
à epb ont le choix entre dix choix
il semblerait sait jamais a compris
qu'ils ont droit en fait en réalité à 20
sous choix est ce que ça ne va pas
engorger justement toutes les
universités en même temps ce d'autant
plus qu'il n'y aura pas de
hiérarchisation
dans les voeux est ce qu'en fait c'est
pas une énorme usine à gaz en fait il en
train de se préparer
déjà ce qu'on en place des parcours sub
ssa met fin à une injustice qui était
absolument insupportable qui était celle
du tirage au sort qui faisaient que vous
n'étiez pas orienter et la sélection se
faisait de manière totalement unique
c'est-à-dire en fonction des zones aucun
des témoins qui étaient parfois des
choix dans des filières sous deux
tensions et bien vous aviez des
bacheliers qui avait toutes les
compétences pour pouvoir accéder aux
supérieurs et aux choix qui les avait
voulu faire et ils étaient tirés au sort
et certains d'entre eux se retrouvait
sans affectation donc parcours super ça
met fin à sa déjà et personne ne peut
dire que le système qui préexistait
qu'était un système par tirage au sort
et est quelque chose qui était
satisfaisant bonjour lui vous avez en
effet jusqu'à 10 veux qu'ils peuvent
être émis avant vous aviez 24e veut vous
avez aujourd'hui 10 veut ce qui est
quand même un choix extrêmement large
une palette extrêmement large pouvait
réaliser et qui en effet va devoir
encore une fois être accompagnée avec
une orientation notamment dès la
première vous avez la mise en place de
deux professeurs principaux notamment
pour vous accompagner aussi dans ses
choix d'orientation c'est très important
qu'on puisse les prendre en charge
évidemment dès la première je suis la
terminale pour les accompagner parce que
déjà 10 juin c'est beaucoup général vous
avez quand même un projet qu un petit
peu plus abouti que cela quand vous
voulez accéder à des études supérieures
tout se passe pour le meilleur de monde
pas exactement d'accord avec ce point de
vue effectivement la mise en place de
parcours super met fin à l'anomalie du
tirage au sort mais pourquoi il y avait
eu un tirage au sort à la rigueur il n'y
en avait pas ce que depuis un certain
nombre d'années il ya de plus en plus
d'étudiants qui accèdent à
l'enseignement supérieur c'est ceux qui
sont nés lors du baby boom de début
d'année 2011 sans que les moyens
financiers ne but
ne suivaient pas derrière nous en dix
ans le budget moyen par étudiant investi
par étapes c'est 10 % ce qui fait que 20
de plus amples éditions ex des
adversaires mais le nombre de places
ouvertes n'augmentez pas donc c'est pour
ça qu'il y avait eu bourrage au sort à
l'heure actuelle donc est-ce que
sélectionner entre l'université va
régler ce problème
déjà non puisque les moyens ne suivent
pas derrière on va créer 22 mille places
alors ses quarante mille étudiants qui
vont arriver à la lumière tel l'année
prochaine déjà on entend déjà ou métaux
etc alors plus d'étudiants qui
arriveront dans tous les cas se réglera
pas ce problème et surtout sur le
constat d'échec une fière c'est
effectivement on connaît la répartition
sauf qu'il faut se rappeler que quand on
connaît les statistiques du ministère
c'était déjà le même cas dans les années
60 donc est ce que le fait qu'il est de
plus en plus à l'université et augmenter
ses parts d'échec ce n'est pas forcément
le carré du coup c'est se tromper de
réponse de dire que bien mise en place
de parcours sûr on va régler le problème
et un dernier point le fait qu'on m'ait
dit veut mais qui ne seront pas hier
chizé c'est à dire qu'auparavant on
pouvait dire telle filière je la mets en
premier voeu 1 ci-dessus ainsi de suite
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas derrière ces
rations de riz veut ce qui fait que
toutes les universités recevront les
voeux de tous les étudiants est ce qui
fait qu on part d'une situation où il ya
déjà trop de filières en tension à une
situation quasiment toutes les filières
sur l'intention de moins et donc
pratiquement une sélection et qui ne
veut résoudre ce problème
d'accord cependant encore une fois les
universités est financée par des fonds
publics donc c'est toujours un peu
compliqué de toujours demander plus
d'argent public pour les universités et
d'autre part en préparant cette émission
j'ai découvert en fait un sondage ifop
pour le magazine l'express qui a été
publié en décembre 2010 est où ils
disent que 73 % des français sont
favorables ou plutôt favorables à une
sélection sur dossier à l'entrée de
l'université
est-ce que vous ça vous choque ou vous
justement il ne faut pas avoir cette
sélection par la méritocratie
je pense que cette section a n'a pas de
sens déjà elle bute de l'instrument
super c'est permettre plus grand nombre
un texte et la réussite d'obtenir un
diplôme national il faut rappeler une
chose le baccalauréat ou d'un diplôme de
licence n'est pas un concours c'est pas
parce que plus de personnes y accèdent
plus de personnes loppsi 2
l'obtiennent que le niveau de diplôme
elle avait quitté ce diplôme va baisser
donc aujourd'hui le fait que 80 % d'une
classe d'âge obtient un bac leur à main
c'est à dire que 80 % une classe d'âge
obtiennent tant de compétences et tant
de connaissances et je pense est une
chose dont il faut se féliciter
je pense qu'il faut solliciter qu'un
certain nombre de lycéens veulent
poursuivre leurs études lancement
supérieur donc déjà faut se rappeler que
ce n'est pas le cas de tout le monde la
majorité disent impressionnés
technologique ne poursuit pas leurs
études
aujourd'hui et quant à la sélection je
vois pas en quoi serait quelque chose de
positif
on rappelle quand même que le cd austin
que deux en 2020 on en croît de 2
millions de diplômés de l'enseignement
supérieur
autant d'ingénieurs autant de cadres qui
demain permettre à la france d'affronter
tous les enjeux de la création numérique
écologique donc d'un point de vue
économique déjà cette section n'a pas de
sens et d'un point de vue humain d'un
point de vue moral et philosophique le
but de l'enseignement supérieur c'est de
permettre à tous dès qu'un stand de
compétences d'accéder à la réussite et
mettre en place cette section teckel
effet aujourd'hui des failles ne
résoudra pas les problèmes de
l'université et deuxièmement une
première c'est si on veut centre un peu
le débat sur notre territoire moi je
voudrais qu'on mette les choses à plat
on est sur un territoire où on a absorbé
on travaille de façon assez concertée
avec le rectorat l'année dernière on a
été en mesure d'absorber tous les
bacheliers qui était dans une situation
difficile à la rentrée c'est à dire que
le travail se main dans la main c'est la
coopération pour justement que personne
ne reste sur le carreau après je partage
évidemment les valeurs universitaires
que vous défendez la à l'université
c'est un lieu de savoir c'est un lieu de
connaissance évidemment qu'il faut
pouvoir accueillir les bacheliers au
sein des universités
oui évidemment je suis d'accord avec
vous aussi il faut des moyens mais il me
semble que là des moyens sont débloqués
que ces moyens là il devrait nous
permettre de progresser sans sa
suffisance moyens alors ils sont ils
suffisants on est le je pourrais vous
dire ils le seront jamais dans la mesure
où il s'agit là d'un enjeu de société
majeur de former les générations futures
donc évidemment plan des moyens plus je
vais vous dire on va faire la
transformation pédagogique du numérique
toutefois là il ya quand même des moyens
qui sont associés à cette transformation
et ça va permettre de récompenser de
reconnaître le travail des équipes
pédagogiques fin quand je reviens sur ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure on est
capable de faire réussir à l'université
de versailles saint quentin les
étudiants à peu près à hauteur de 50%
cirque on est capable de le faire
ça repose sur un investissement sur des
équipes pédagogiques un savoir-faire
soit 10% de moins que la moyenne de
chaque en l1 qui est de 60% en voile oui
si vous voulez entre les abandons etc
mais oui on est capable de faire ça et
on laisse personne sur le carreau moi je
reviens à ce qui a été dit effectivement
l'aberration c'était de tirage au sort
là je suis effectivement c'est hors
valeurs les valeurs universitaires sait
accueillir les jeunes et les accompagner
dans leur projet de formation
je voudrais réagir également à ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure sur les voeux
la différence là ces qui a dit veut mais
que ces dits veut doivent être motivés
on a un projet de formation derrière ce
à dire que les les professeurs
principaux vont accompagner les
bacheliers pour qu'ils construisent un
projet et que ce projet y correspondent
à quelque chose à un désir une envie et
que ça il y en aura 10 mai 10 réel et
que ça pour nous c'est essentiel puisque
ça permet d'accompagner et d'orienter
j'entends les termes sélection etc
pour moi ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
c'est orienté ce n'est pas une sélection
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une sélection
puisqu'il ya une garantie vous pouvez
accéder à l'enseignement supérieur
dire que chaque bachelier à un accès à
l'enseignement supérieur c'est ça qu'on
met en place on met fin encore une fois
à une équité évidente qui était le
tirage au sort et accents aujourd'hui la
sélection elles existent elles existent
par l'échec
elles existent parce que vous avez 60 %
d'étudiants qui à l'issue de leur
première année échoue ou abandonnent 60%
je pense pas que ce soit une situation
qui est satisfaisante et vous n'avez pas
de sélection pourtant à l'entrée mais
vous avez 60 % à l'issue de leur
première année qui échoue qui abandonne
est ce que c'est vrai aujourd'hui
potentiellement des deux reprises en
début de section si on peut parler de ça
comme ça notamment sur tous ceux qui
sont les filières sous tension je pense
au droit la première année d'études de
médecine ou alors dans l'université de
51,10 via notamment la descente est
monstration économique que social ou
alors la filière maths physique chimie
informatique vous allez mettre en place
notamment des
comme on appelle ça des attendus est ce
que justement c'est attendu ne vont pas
se transformer en un critère de
sélection implicite mais c'est ce qui a
été dit c'est à dire que vous avez les
étudiantes des bacheliers qui vont
émettre 10 veut dit veux qu'ils vont
motiver les universités vont ensuite
leurs maîtres plusieurs réponses soient
elles vont indien oui tout simplement
oui vous pouvez venir chez nous la place
disponible etc
ou alors elles vont dire oui si oui si
et là vous avez un parcours justement
qui est un parcours d'orientation et
d'accompagnement
est ce que on accepte de ceux d'être
honnête et de dire que en fonction des
différents bacs que vous avez eue
vous ne pouvez pas forcément aller
n'importe où parce que sinon on vous
voit juste vous conduire droit à l'échec
donc on peut continuer et on peut
continuer à avoir 30% des étudiants qui
abandonnent l'autre en fonction des
étudiants qui échouent à l'issue de leur
première année
oui ça c'est bien on fait pas de
sélection mais on fait une sélection par
l'échec ou alors on peut dire
l'université elle est dans son rôle
elle en son rôle d'accompagnement et
quelqu'un en fonction du bac qu'il a eue
en fonction des compétences qui sont les
siennes et bien il aura une remise à
niveau
parce qu'il aura pas forcément eu le
bagage nécessaire initial et donc il va
être accompagné pendant un trimestre
pendant 1 semaine jusqu'à une année pour
être formés pour être armé et pour
réussir parce que c'est ça l'enjeu c'est
à la fois qu'il réussit ses études
supérieures et c'est qu'ils puissent
s'insérer ensuite dans la vie privée de
l'érection oui c'est de réagir sur trois
points ferme sur la question de
l'orientation et le projet de loi
s'appelle orientations et réussite des
étudiants et pourtant par dessalement
est très peu de chose qui est dit sur la
nation elle peut de chose qui est dit
qu'il serait intéressant le fait que les
deux professeurs principaux
en terminale par exemple sur deux choses
ne sera pas assez mise en place
puisqu'on sait aujourd'hui le snes qui
le premier syndicat au lycée elle estime
que seulement la moitié des lycées ont
les moyens financiers ont eu les moyens
financiers pour mettre en place ce
dispositif donc des mesures qui sont
intéressantes mais insuffisante et qui
ne sont insuffisamment financées il donc
ne seront pas mises en place
ça c'est la première chose deuxième
insurrection des moyens budgétaires
aujourd'hui la stran est ce qu'un
organisme de gouvernementale nom qui
n'est pas quelque chose qui est
partisans estiment qu'il faudrait 1,5
milliard d'euros par an pour plus et
universités fonctionnent correctement
le projet de loi tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui et je t'en sers un milliard
sur cinq ans donc on voit bien
aujourd'hui se poursuit lisait on voit
bien oui oui et oui mais sauf que
l'arrière milliards en juste 1 milliard
et un gardien plus 1 milliard oui juste
ans alors qu'elle est aujourd'hui il
faudrait un milliard cinq par an alors
l'angleterre 1 milliards sur cinq ans et
huit mois
cet argent doit donc un projet loi qui
n'est pas financé et qui montre que dans
tous les cas il y aura des étudiants qui
seront laissés sur 15
alors rentré je tiens à rappeler sept
dix mille étudiants à peu près qu'il
n'avait pas de place à l'université
aujourd'hui
et donc quand on fait un projet de loi
qui met en place il faut le dire la
section entraîneur c'était qui n'est pas
financé bah oui ce sera encore plus
d'élites sur yon qui sont laissés sur le
carreau et à londres est juste un truc
rapidement on dit aujourd'hui un échec
alors qu'il n'ya pas de sélection
pourtant c'est pas parce qu'il n'ya pas
de sélection qui vient des chaouis un
échec mais c'est pas les causes
aujourd'hui presque pas de cet échec
on sait c'est le salariat étudiant on
sait c'est le manque
2 c'est le manque c'est cesser la
vieillesse des méthodes pédagogiques
aujourd'hui c'est le manque de rien dans
l'université on parlait bordés est prêt
mais dire que il ya un échec aujourd'hui
donc il faut mettre en place la
sélection à l'ensemble des étudiants qui
abandonnent ou qui est chauve ne sont
pas dues soit à la vieillesse comme vous
dites des méthodes pédagogiques soit
parce qu'ils sont des étudiants salariés
c'est aussi peut-être parce que on les
conduit vers des formations dans
lesquels ils n'ont pas été ni orienté ni
accompagné et c'est peut-être ça qui
change lui deux faits sur le dessus
harnais sur plusieurs sujets qui se
superposent je vais revenir juste
rebondir sur le salariat évidemment
c'est une problématique le statut des
étudiants salariés on le prend on le
prend à bras le corps dans les
universités on reconnaît ce statut
étudiant vous êtes là pour en témoigner
on le reconnaît on prend en compte on
aménage on essaie de faire notre
transformation pédagogique choisi fut
contré un mois donc je pense que
l'université avant se transforme à côté
de ça je reviens sur le territoire oui
en nous déplaçant plus ou minutes sur le
carreau mais non moi je vous dis on
ouvre près de 400 places en plus pour
absorber les flux vont dit de sélection
ils vont échouer
non aujourd'hui on a quelque chose qui
est quand même qui va dans le bon sens
quand auparavant en avignon une
sélection des dossiers qui s'opérait
vergara algorithmes cet algorithme et il
ne laissait pas de place à la décision
humaine là aujourd'hui ce qu'on fait
c'est qu'on va prendre 3000 4000
dossiers par filière et on va les
étudier un par un avec une dimension
humaine un projet de formation a motivé
crime nations notamment pour les lycéens
qui sont justement de laisser
défavorisés qui n'auront pas forcément
les attendus pourquoi pourquoi de la
discrimination est donc au contraire
plutôt que d'avoir une machine qui
affecte en fonction de notes en fonction
de là on aurait des critères qui seront
des critères qu'elle est projet de quoi
il a menti qu'elle est secrétaire par
exemple en entrée de première année de
droit
alors c'est ce n'est pas uniquement les
notes ce n'est pas uniquement et ben en
fait on va on va regarder les attendus
qui sue qui sont sortis aujourd'hui sont
des attendus de très générique ça va
être avoir des capacités de raisonnement
logique avoir un niveau en langues
acceptable ce sont des choses comme ça
donc après tout dépend l'appropriation
que fait l'enseignement secondaire de
ses attendus
et précisément pour ça on travaille main
dans la main
saignements secondaire lot 6 février ont
rassemblé proviseur en principe des
professeurs principaux les les
conseillères d'orientation pour leur
expliquer ce qu'on attend à l'université
ce que signifie cet attendu pour que eux
mêmes puissent les expliquer aux lycéens
pour qu'ils fassent leur choix
d'orientation
donc il ya du vrai ya du faux mais dans
tous les cas faut nuancer
on va dans le bon sens on va étudier
énormément de dossiers pour les équipes
pédagogiques c'est encore une fois
beaucoup de travail mais c'est positif
et aujourd'hui c'est absorbé par les
équipes et ça ça va dans le bon sens
pour être un dernier mot sur les moyens
je voudrais juste revenir sur ce que
disait monsieur chili là où je suis
d'accord et où jeu par rapport à ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure aujourd'hui
on est capable de mettre en place de
faire la cde pour garder les dossiers de
mettre en place un certain nombre de
choses mais les parcours ou bicis et
parcours d'accompagnement qui va falloir
mettre en place en transverse pour dire
un un jeune b tient il faut alors tu
fasses un peu de méthode au un peu
d'anglais et c'est ça aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué financièrement de les mettre
en place parce que les voilà au niveau
des universités budgétairement oui c'est
compliqué donc les moyens sont
débloquées ils le seront progressivement
de plus en plus j'espère qu'on puisse
mettre en place et parcours passait
justement n'est pas en train de ce2
refont notamment tout ce qui est
formation à l'université
peut-être débouchés dans des formations
un peu plus professionnalisantes pour
moi universitaire est ce que c'est vers
ça où on dit paquet des formations
doivent être moins universitaire on
garde la plénitude des formations telles
qu'elles existent c'est juste qu'on a
encore une fois un accompagnement qui à
la fois une orientation au préalable
là où elle était objectivement caduque
et tout le monde reconnaît que
l'orientation aujourd'hui elle est assez
déficiente
non seulement au lycée mais même avant
dans les choix d'orientation qui sont
faire dans le secondaire et puis ensuite
un accompagnement justement parce que
grâce à ses attendus mais c'est aussi
beaucoup mieux pour le bachelier il et
c'est justement ce qui est requis ce qui
est attendu de lui ce qui n'est pas
toujours le cas il sait aussi qu'elle le
niveau d'insertion professionnelle dans
les différentes filières qu'il choisit
parce que c'est aussi un des critères
qu'on peut avoir en tant que belge
alliés savoir à la fois qu'est ce qu'on
attend de moi si demain j'accède à telle
ou telle formation
et puis qu'est ce que moi je peut en
attendre pour ma vie professionnelle
future
et je pense que ça c'est une
transparence que l'on doit aux
différents ateliers pour qu'ils sachent
dans comment ils doivent s'engager dans
leurs études supérieures
et ça c'est cet accompagnement nouveau
qui est accordé et qui me paraît
extrêmement profitable encore profitable
je pense faut pas être hypocrite sur le
système éducatif français on sait qu'il
reproduit très fortement les inégalités
sociales aujourd'hui on le sait la
région elle n'est pas choisi en france
soir en troisième que c'est en seconde
ou en terminale à chaque fois
l'orientation et son implantation qui
est subi douanière sociale en troisième
les mausolées vend directement est
classé en filière professionnelle
idéalement ce qu'on dit m
à la fin du bac au leurre à ceux qui
n'auraient pas à ce niveau ce qui
viendrait qui n'aurait peut-être que tu
as le passé les bains s'autocensurent et
ne poursuit pas leurs études à
l'université c'est attendu avant
première ce fut vraiment faire ça ils
vont faire qu'on va renforcer
l'autocensure des lycéens aujourd'hui et
on le sait on connaît les chiffres tant
d'ouvriers dans les taux d'enfants
d'ouvriers dans les licences il est
extrêmement bas al'inverse des enfants
de cadres et professions supérieures et
donc on ne sait ya une révolution
sociale qui se fait aujourd'hui à
l'université donc cette sélection elle
va juste renfort à quitter cela est
renforcé encore plus cette pollution
ployer pas l'accent sur l'action de
l'orientation des futures ans est l'une
des principales causes de l'échec à
venir ce thème mais parce qu'elle ait
subi et n'ont pas choisi parce qu'il
n'ya pas des moyens financiers et
humains qui est mis au collège au lycée
pour mener cette orientation et pour
répondre vraiment pourquoi il ya un
échec on y est et pourquoi il faut
changer uni est resté là encore je le
dis le salariat étudiant effectivement
levés ce qu on fait pas mal de choses
sur ce jeu là mais ça reste la première
cause d'échec universités sur la
question de la précarité étudiante le
gréement ne fait pas grand chose pour
lutter face à l'heure actuelle déjà je
prouve assez étonnant ce que vous dites
c'est à dire que vous partez du principe
que parce que vous êtes un jeune qui
vient d'un milieu défavorisé
forcément vous seriez pas en capacité de
comprendre les attendus qui vous sont
demandées et donc d'accéder à des études
supérieures je vois pas pourquoi
d'autre part d'autre part c'est en
milieu en tout cas dans vos propos alors
j'ai pas bien compris peut-être que ce
n'est peut-être pas un expliqué mais
d'autre part sur la formation
professionnelle
on a ouvert une mission officielle
bancaire travaille dessus vous savez
quel est le taux d'insertion dans la vie
professionnelle de ceux qui justement
ont bénéficié de ces formations
professionnalisantes
il est beaucoup plus élevé qu'à
l'université donc c'est pas du tout des
voies de garage
donc je suis désolé mais on a tous
insisté juste je finis juste on a tous
un discours à mon avis à porter on peut
soulever évidemment de valorisation de
l'université de mais aussi de
valorisation de la voie professionnelle
parce que si vous même en tant que
syndicat étudiant vous dites ici sur un
plateau qui est peut-être gardé par des
bacheliers ou notamment par des parents
vous leur dites attention parce que la
voie de garage c'est quand même la voie
professionnelle on envoie les mauvais
élèves vous accentuez ce discours là
maintenant justement la voie
professionnelle
y at il un ingénieur du son village ne
s'est pas fait ressentir dans cette
formation le raid était injuste des
élèves des étudiants ya aussi un fils
sont sous financées et qui deviennent ne
sont justement pas des voies de garage
quand vous avez 70 % des jeunes qui sut
qui suivent ces formations et qui sont
ensuite insérer dans la vie
professionnelle et qui sont dans des
taux d'emploi et d'insertion
professionnelle qui sont extrêmement
puissants
dès la sortie de leurs études donc je
pense qu'on a tous un discours qu un
discours responsable à tenir et vous
vous devez aussi le tenir je suis désolé
en tant que syndicat étudiant qui est de
dire aux parents qui nous regardent que
justement ce ne sont pas des voies de
garage parce que l'insertion
professionnelle il est très puissant et
en plus il ya une diversité des métiers
par crainte c'était très bien une
première chose c'est que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure et 80 % d'une classe
d'âge au baccalauréat
ça traduit bien l'évolution du système
d'enseignement cela vous dit on
reproduit sans arrêt les les milieux
défavorisés qui n'arrivent pas à
l'université etc
c'est fou on a 80 % d'une classe d'âge
au bac c'était pas vrai il ya vingt ans
ça l'était encore moins ya 50 on avance
le reconnaître à dire
on va finir je suis très attaché aux
valeurs universitaires et à
l'enseignement public je pense qu'on est
on a précisément un modèle certes il
n'est pas parfait modèle encore une fois
qui évolue c'est un modèle qui permet
justement à des jeunes quel que soit le
milieu duquel ils viennent de d'accéder
à l'enseignement supérieur
contrairement à beaucoup de pays dans le
monde ce modèle là il faut défendre
je pense que là dessus nous sommes
d'accord et au tous les trois autour de
la table nous sommes donc ce sont des
valeurs qu'on protège mais c'est plus te
ment parce qu'on les protège qu'à un
moment donné il faut aussi les penser
différemment elle ne pas être dans
l'immobilisme
il faut accompagner la transformation de
l'université l'accompagnement des de
cette génération qui est de plus en plus
importante c'est tout il ya un dédit
d'où on prend en compte quel futur pour
les universités meilleur selon vous on
va faire un dernier petit tour de table
de minutes chacun on commence par là on
va finir comme ça désormais j'attends
beaucoup de cette réforme qui est
engagée car un premier pas on sait très
bien on avait une urgence qui était de
remplacer apb il va falloir qu'on puisse
aussi faire l'évaluation des après la
rentrée prochaine où on voit qu'il ya eu
plusieurs centaines de milliers de feux
qui ont déjà été formulées en une
semaine donc ça veut dire que c'est déjà
une plateforme qui fonctionne ce qui
était important parce que c'était une
inquiétude aussi très fortes notamment
des familles centaines de milliers de
veut ça montre que ça fonctionne et je
pense qu'il faut après sur la question
de l'université en effet qu'ils aient
une meilleure coordination et qui se met
en place dans les territoires justement
entre l'enseignement secondaire et
l'enseignement supérieur
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera
à travailler l'idée de mettre en place
deux professeurs principaux c'est
justement permettre qu'ils aient plus de
fluidité qui est plus de transparence et
qui est une meilleure orientation et
enfin je pense que c'est les études
supérieures dans leur ensemble et moi
j'insiste beaucoup sur la question de la
formation et de la voie professionnelle
parce que justement quand vous parlez
d'autocensure il ya aussi d'autres
autocensure de famille qui considère que
justement comme sont des voies de garage
leurs enfants qui souhaitent accéder à
la voie professionnelle ne devrait pas y
aller
voie professionnelle aujourd'hui elle
est extraordinairement diverses vous
avez des ingénieurs qui sont dans la
voie professionnelle celui à airbus qui
est pas loin aujourd'hui ils n'arrivent
pas à recruter sur des métiers qui sont
des voeux devenus des métiers rares
je voudrais y est par exemple et qui
sont des métiers pourtant de
qualification des jeunes vers 7 heures
en ce sens il est étudiant et c'est un
autre en bas et par delà la parole
notamment qu il
avenir pour l'union cgt ont déjà tout
n'est pas noir effectivement pour
l'universitaire et pour l'unité
française et effectivement il faut
changer des choses notamment comparé
d'immobilisme je tiens à rappeler que ce
projet de loi il ressemble quasiment mot
pour mot aux projets de vaquer dans 86
ans qui montre que ce projet n'est pas
extrêmement moderne s'apprend chose que
je voulais dire quant à l'avenir du
ministre française premièrement il doit
se faire à moyens à moyens budgétaires
qui correspondent aux besoins de
l'université ce qui n'aurait pour ce à
quoi ne répond pas ce projet de loi le
rituel projet de loi qui n'a pas encore
été votée je tiens à souligner que vous
lui at on assez de l'université qui
applique un projet de loi qui n'a pas
encore été voté définitivement faire ça
c'est scandaleux
quant à l'avenir devenir ces français je
pense il faut premièrement se dire que
c'est l'université qui doit ne sont pas
les étudiants qui devraient s'adapter à
venir team puis j'ai dû me retenir cet
été aux étudiants on donne des ordres
des injonctions du soutien de pierre
tant d'années je pense que c'est la
question du renouveau des méthodes
pédagogiques sur la question de
l'orientation sur la question de la
lutte contre la précarité
l'augmentation des bourses augmenté
nombre de boursiers ce sont des mesures
qui permettraient de réduire l'échec en
licence qui permettrait de porter le
plus con ditions vers le site et ce vers
quoi il faut se tourner c'est parce que
c'est vraiment quel meilleur avenir pour
les universités ah ben je vous dirais la
transformation pédagogique est justement
l'accompagnement les équipes
enfin les universités ces dernières
années ont parfois été en souffrance en
souffrance pour des questions de moyens
aujourd'hui il ya une prise de
conscience collective de ce que
représente l'université et des enjeux
que ça pour l'avenir de notre pays
cette prise de conscience est très bien
qu'elle arrive maintenant c'est très
bien que le gouvernement se disent qu'à
un moment donné il va accompagner
financièrement ces efforts je reviens
encore une fois sur le savoir faire on a
un savoir faire on est des choses qu'on
est capable de porter on est capable
d'amener les jeunes à la réussite à
l'insertion professionnelle
il faut nous aider à faire cela on a
épuisé un petit peu des bonnes volontés
des fois dans les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur en france ces
dernières années ont été vraiment
difficiles là aujourd'hui qu'on le
considère et qu'on reconnaisse cet
investissement ne semble un enjeu majeur
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ces
missions d'avoir des battues avec autant
d'enthousiasmé quant à nous je vous
invite à voir à revoir cette émission
sur notre site internet passent une
agréable soirée et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]